Hello everyone. I'm Elmer Thomas,
principal developer educator at Twilio.
Welcome to the AI engineer world's fair.
Our talk today is called the robots are
coming for your job. And that's okay.
Don't worry, the title is tongue and
cheek. I'm here to show you why AI isn't
something to fear. It's something we can
embrace to work smarter. In the next few
minutes, you'll see how our relatively
tiny docs team uses AI agents to
turbocharge workflows instead of trying
to replace ourselves. We'll look at the
pain points, the agents we built, and
the guard rails that keep us accurate.
I've been a developer and builder for
decades. Trends come and go. AI is the
latest big one. Like many of you, I
wondered how it would change our
day-to-day work. Today, you'll see what
we've learned, warts and all. My
colleague Maria Bermudez, a lead
developer of our AI Docs buddy and
resident backlog busting coffee fanatic,
will drive a live agent walkthrough so
you can judge the results yourself.
Here's a game plan. We'll cover the
pain, our agent architecture, Maria's
demo, and a road map that you can steal
for your own team. Let's dive in.
Picture this. A tiny doc team, a flood
of Jira tickets. Three headaches jump
out. Number one, errorprone first drafts
from 100 plus product teams. Two,
time-sync grooming like style checks,
alt text, SEO. Three, hallucination risk
if we let Jedi run wild. We needed
leverage, not
burnout. Instead of one megabot, we
built six singlepurpose agents behind a
simple next.js frontend. The automated
edi editor fixes grammar, formatting,
and
accuracy. Image alt tech gen text text
generator gives you instant
accessibility wins. The jargon
simplifier turns dev into plain English.
SEO
metadata provides title and description
and character keeping it character count
safe. The docs outline builder
recommends nav and structure. That's
coming soon. Super excited about that.
Our Slack Backbot helps triage help
channel
requests. Each agent tackles a
repetitive well scoped job so humans can
focus on judgment and clarity.
Rule of thumb, pick tasks that are
repeatable, high volume, and low
creativity. That's the sweet spot for an
AI helper. Here's the flow behind every
request. We have a
NexJS UI that feeds into a custom
GPT401 agent. We use the appropriate
model for the particular job. The custom
GPT is it has our style guide and it has
our rubric that is baked in. It's
actually retrieved from an air table so
that folks can easily collaborate on it.
We have a validation layer that includes
veil linting and CI/CD tests. The GitHub
PR adds codeowner review. It makes it
much easier for us to scrutinize the
changes that the agents are suggesting.
A human hits the merge only when it's
right. And usually we have built into
their product and engineering reviews as
well. So we have several human eyes
before we actually consider hitting that
merge button. This layered approach, it
crushes hallucinations without showing
us down. Maybe not crushes them, but it
reduces them significantly.
All right, it's time to prove this isn't
vaporware. I'm handing the screen to
Maria Bermudez, the brains behind much
of the AI Docs buddy code. Maria, take
it away. Thank you, Elmer. So, real
quick, I want to show you how we use
Copilot to autogenerate our overview and
release those page. And from here, you
can get into any of the agents that you
want to work with. So, I'm going to
start with the automated editor. One
cool thing about this is you not only
can load an MDX file, uh, a markdown
file, but you can also plug in a live
URL. And I'm going to do that option
right
now. This does take a little while. So,
we added this graphic here because we're
using the 01 model. We've done a lot of
experimentation and figured out this is
the best model to consistently apply our
style guide and
rubric. And here you go. And then on
the it shows you the diff of what it
changed and in the changes made tab you
actually have a list of um explanation
of the original text, the revised text
and what it changed and what style
guidance and rubric item the changes
pertain to. Um it's not perfect as as
you can see like um sometimes it catches
that there's a missing SEO description
but other times it doesn't. So luckily
we have an SEO metadata generator and
I'm going to plug in this page into that
one.
So, what I'm actually going to do is I'm
going to upload the
file and then go back to conversational
intelligence. So, now I'm going to
generate SEO metadata for that same page
that we just edited.
And there you go. So it generates a
metatitle. So you have to specify if you
don't want that. And then it gives you
the meta description um accounting for
character
limitations. And now I'm going to show
you the alt text
generator. It has the same option that
we have where you can plug in a live
URL. But I'm going to show you um
picking multiple pages
and having our agent generate all text
for all of those images. So I'm going to
click on generate all text
now. And you see how quickly that got
done and it also conforms to the format
that we require from our docs platform.
And lastly, I'm going to show you the
jargon simplifier. So, you can take
whatever like pages that you're
reviewing. This is really helpful not
only for writing, but when we're
reviewing a poll request, and it gives
us like a good way to provide quick
edits to those images. So, I'm going to
plug in a text that I've prepared, and
I'm going to click on simplify.
And there you go. It also gives you a
div like or editor. And on the next tab,
you have the revised text that you can
quickly copy and apply as a pull request
uh comment or just edit the file
directly. And that's it. We're working
on making our agents talk to each other
eventually, but we we have a lot of work
to do on that front. Thank you, Maria.
That was wonderful. Now, tools alone
don't guarantee quality. Our guard rails
tackle three big risks.
Hallucinations. We use tools like Veil
Lint and CI test to help mitigate that
in combination with the various eyes of
of human
stakeholders. Bias, data set tests, and
prompt audits are the way to tackle
those issues. Stakeholder misalignment.
So weekly PR reviews, sometimes these
are compressed into days and sometimes
hours. And we also have Slack feedback
loops generally with the product
managers and engineering team. These
feedback cycles, they let us tune the
prompts continuously instead of hoping
the model magically stays
perfect. Now, please steal this
three-step playbook. Identify one pain
that's killing throughput. Two, pick a
single task that's repeatable and
rule-based. And then three, loop with
your users weekly at least. Ship,
measure, and refine. Stack a few of
these wins and watch your team's
velocity jump. Thanks again to the AI
engineer World's Fair team for hosting
us. And thanks to you for spending time
with us today. Big shout out to Carly
Vanderwart, our manager at Twilio, who
keeps encouraging us to push the
boundaries with AI along with the rest
of our leadership. We appreciate your
attention. Now go build something
amazing with AI.